so what we're gonna do is I just want to
walk you through this together just so
you have me a bit of an example we'll
look at some data what this is about is
about you get given data and you want to
get some meaning out of it right dad I
can't tell you what it means you have to
pose it questions and in fact that's
often the hardest part what questions
should you pose like you have to think
of the questions to put to a set of data
the questions that you ask will define
the kinds of things that you get out of
data so let's just start with the basics
first have a look at this we don't ever
carry in the class but I don't know if
you can call for 9/11 Gulf so you can
see one two three all the way up so nine
it even mentions for you which is
helpful usually the player with the
lowest final score with this can anyone
tell me why why is a low score good yeah
fantastic so if you're uncoordinated
like me right you have to hit so many
times to get closer and then even when
you're right there you're like oh I
missed again and you miss so that's why
we smooth the small ANOVA not with my
tackles in a smaller number means fewer
hits which is better that means your way
okay so you can see here it says for
each player finder me mode media okay
can just take a minute you'll need to
book there obviously the mode you can
simply read off have a look at carries
have a look at her scores they're not in
any order but you can quickly see the
mode cut you
it's eight that's right one two three of
them there what about Laura what's her
mode we check for to me
so that's easy to read off the rest of
them requires some calculation and reap
watery so you can do to you calculator
if you like entirely can you spend a
minute doing that and then we'll come
back and discuss you're starting to make
a bit of progress here now what I've
done the question doesn't tell you to do
this however if you have a look at where
the parts are going you can see that
eventually what we want to do it's all
of this comparison we want to argue
who's better right who's better and if
you might look at Part D apart area
what's what's with that who's really
better and the point is in the real
world there's not what this player is
clearly the best or this clear is clear
this it's far more frequent that you get
you've got a gray area it's like well
someone's better in these regards and
then someone else is better in these
regards so what I've done to be able to
compare them nice and easily is we've
been asked to work out six things for
each of these um for each of these
players you can see the band is the main
mode median range interquartile range
and standard deviation you can write SD
if you prefer but this is what meant it
was calculated sis so that's why I've
written it we've already identified I
think the move for each of them I think
was eight and four who's got to meet
these five
and we get them can we get carries
exactly suit and go who's go already
okay I'll just put 6.1 I'll put you
right I see sorry okay that's pinup okay
who's gonna meet him already okay okay
all right now those took a bit of
calculation but again some of the other
ones you can work out like to the range
we already found out carries mode
happens to be her highest between to a
worst score so we already know the
highest one is what's her best score
we're talking I think it's all four
which is a score of three so we can
already say her range is going to be
five and Laura so we've got the same
best score but she has a really really
bad score doesn't she which is the final
hole so she's got fifty which means her
ranges well however you'll notice as
soon as you go to interquartile range
okay you're gonna need to work out what
the lower quartile q1 is a q3 is but you
can immediately see this is not going to
be counted into interquartile range do
you agree that's kind of the point of
the interquartile range to take those
really wheat allies and take them away
from your calculation we've done our
calculations we know what's good here so
here comes the important part he comes
the analysis part we want to make an
argument off of this data that one of
the players is better than me Anna so
I've got my scores here right now by the
way if you didn't get asked any of these
questions at all and you just got given
the numbers what would be your go-to
place your first if you can only
calculate one thing what would be the
thing you calculate that tells you who
is better yeah
I think me is a pretty normal place for
us to go which is why rightly it's first
and you can see the image that it
portrays is not very meaningful right
like a difference of 0.1 is so
insignificant but off the base of that
number alone it's difficult to argue
that one player is vastly better than
another okay in fact if you have a look
the mean adds up all the scores right so
it's just really one hit different in
total does that make sense that's the
only thing that accounts for that zero
point one of difference which might have
just been you know like the like I don't
know Laura sneezed when she hit one of
the balls so that's why it just went off
and then after that they were exactly
the same okay so you can see from here
we don't have much to meaningfully
compare or contrast all right let's go
down a little further can you make an
argument from the mode what do you think
yeah what's your what would be the
argument that you make
[Music]
so when we make an argue about
consistent right the mode is an
important number to use to argue and
consistency because it's the thing that
happens most often right so that's fair
enough
however is it the only number that tells
you about consistency because if you
look at this this tells you oh cool I if
you look just the most number these are
better twice as better but there's
another number that tells you got
consistency here as well which number is
it I'll eat at least one hour range
tells you about consistency right so
you've got a very wide range there I'd
argue the standard deviation also tells
you about consistency
you know if potentially you've had
someone with a standard deviation of
zero what would that mean about the
games that they play yeah every single
one is perfectly consistent because they
get the same number every single time so
you can see that this number is a really
good guide for encapsulate how
consistent they are across the game so
it's a bit dicey to say from here alone
that laura has a more consistent game
right okay I'm not gonna tell you which
other numbers to look at how would you
make an argument that carries a better
player let's do you some guiding
questions can you point me to dirty
yeah okay so you guys are both going for
standard deviation why is this enough
from a creature to say yeah she's the
player who I would put my money on what
do you think yeah
okay so just more consistent but why is
that a good thing someone could be
consistently bad why is consistency of a
good quality to have a MacGuffin
why is that like okay I'm sorry so just
point out I'm not trying to make money
or anything like that but in Dada when
you're looking at data you try to make
comparisons like this right there are
three questions you have to ask first
you have to ask why right why is the
Daiya the way it is and then when you
have an answer that question like for
example Laura had a really bad game on
the whole life and that was pretty much
just threw her off for the whole thing
right once you have an answer that
question
the second question you have to ask is
why why was that what's special about
whole mind that made it so bad right or
is it something about she has a really
good start to the game and then the
wheels just fall off so actually she's a
player who just gets really tired
is there one known how many game how
many holes a normal game of golf is it's
18 right so maybe that's actually
everything was great and then she just
gets it she's like noble walking I'll do
this okay
so consistency right yeah that's what I
saw these really cool like what a minute
ago two skateboards there anyway I can
ask you guys why and then you asked why
can anyone tell me what the third
question is that you asked why you asked
why again okay
now like I said I'm not trying to be
mean but why is consistency a good thing
why is predictability a good thing
[Music]
so I feel like you guys are giving me
synonyms for the word consistent
predictable reliable constant I know
what do you think yeah so my point here
you're not gonna like this
my point here is I don't actually have
an answer to that question but I need to
the whole point is for you to not just
say oh well I picked equality and that's
that's a good thing
well why is that a good thing
I think if Angelica was trying to make a
point right maybe maybe you've got like
a team of players you want to pick on
your golfed women right well you don't
peek all of them as really really good
sometimes and bad other times like
brilliant but then disappointing
you want some players who are consistent
and maybe you want one whose can make a
can make a whole new ball or something
like that but all the rest of time is
pretty winner all right that was your
the carry can you make an argument for
Laura how can you how can you look at
this data and that data and job
convinced me that actually lowers the
better plan not caring I can think one
of those
okay how many holes did she weed out of
the night
five five right five out of nine and if
you take out like when you look at a
whole line which is that three at home
right if you take that one out find out
at eight find out at eight right because
that was emotional you watching five
that eight is even more of a majority so
clearly if you take into account the
difficulty of the overall each
individual one because you guys know it
like resets every time it's like I'm in
a whole different place now right so the
rules for this whole of this fall are
quite different that she looks better on
paper that's that's an important thing
what else what else how else would you
argue the more is a better plan
[Music]
okay the fifteen which is what made them
look comparable in the first place is an
outlier if we took this out can you
recalculate to me can we calculate
carries mean just now the first eight
holes device I ate then someone else
work out maybe within a pair of one of
you could do one one does the other can
you work out Laura's mean add them up
and divide by eight what do you get if
you change that carries 5.1 and Lawrence
that's a bit more of a stock kind of on
comparison don't you think that shows a
more over that of that sort of part of
the game that's a fairly consistent
difference whereas we said point one was
like there was nothing it's an outlier I
think maybe she just got unlucky right
look maybe she um she hit a once into a
sand trap and then she was just the
stock right whereas she never ever does
that do you see my point is just to pose
questions to the Donna right have a
think about the Donna doesn't tell the
whole story what could account for it
and this is kind of the whole life those
statistics in fact statistics
you guys know how I make a big deal
about babes it's now it is now
compulsory for anyone doing state [ __ ]
about statistics a bit weird though
statistics did not start as a part of
mathematics which is why if you go to
universities you find a School of
Mathematics and statistics it's
something different the word literally
means it's just information about the
state they came from like demographers
and politicians who wanted to understand
human beings and how populations fit
that's why we didn't save any population
that's right so you're going to be in
the position of having data and not
knowing who is better but you have to be
in charge of asking the questions